les attentats de vendredi soir à
ouagadougou nous ont rappelé combien
certaines zones peuvent être dangereuses
même si le burkina faso on en parlait
hier avec sophie langlois était épargnée
jusque là c'est une branche d'al qaïda
qui a revendiqué derrière les attentats
les attentats pardon et non pas le
groupe armé islamique
mathieu proche on vous a demandé un peu
de nous faire la cartographie de ces
groupes terroristes leur implantation en
fait sur la planète et on voit que ça
c'est un sas et ans et puis il faut
d'abord patrice effectivement faire la
distinction entre aqmi al qaïda au
maghreb islamique et le groupe armé état
islamique dont on entend beaucoup parler
depuis un an et demi admis sa zone
d'action c'est le sahel c'est le sud du
sahara et on le voit effectivement sur
cette carte le burkina faso et entourés
de pays très instable ou des groupes
islamistes sont implantés et ils étaient
épargnés jusqu'ici vous le disiez c'est
maintenant fini
mokhtar belmokhtar lui c'est le chef
d'aqmi il veut rester indépendant de la
nébuleuse est à islamique dirigée par
abou baker al bagdadi allant voir
justement dans le fief de l'état
islamique
on se rappelle en 2014 aboubaker al
baidhani convient de voir avait décrété
un califat à cheval sur la syrie et
l'irak depuis un an et demi leur emprise
sur ces deux pays c'est un peu accru
mais depuis quelque temps on note un
certain recul notamment dans les zones
du nord ici au profit les kurdes qui
sont appuyées par les bombardements de
la coalition à jaca notamment la
capitale proclamer des islamistes est
très très très souvent ou mathieu est ce
qu'il faut comprendre
mathieu c'est l'expansion du groupe armé
islamique qui fait des lieux où c'est
avec d'autres groupes partout tout à
fait ce qu'on appelle les allégeances de
certains pays sur cette carte en rouge
ici sont les pays où des cellules de
l'état islamique sont implantées et en
plus foncée ici indonésie philippines la
somalie ici encore le
rien avec boko haram sont des pays où il
ya eu allégeance et puis envers des
zones où il ya eu des attaques soit
revendiqué soit d'inspiration de l'état
islamique
jakarta la semaine dernière évidemment
en novembre en france à paris san
bernardino en californie début décembre
quatorze morts ne faut pas oublier aussi
tout près de chez nous martin couture au
dos à saint-jean-sur-richelieu il était
dans la mire de la grc
parce qu'il voulait se rendre combattre
aux côtés de l'état islamique petite
dernière séquence
regardez tous ces pays c'est seulement
dans les trois derniers mois
toutes les attaques liées à l'état
islamique qui ont été répertoriés donc
on voit le maillage dans le monde entier
à quoi il faut ajouter maintenant ici le
danger de plus en plus forts d'aqmi donc
au burkina faso moi je pense que c'est
très très clair on le voit avec votre
carte la complique la complexité de se
battre contre le groupe armé ta
islamique merci beaucoup mathieu au
revoir à la prochaine